good morning believe nation today's
message is follow the path over to urs D
Tyler I consider myself to be a walking
breathing example of the sort of things
that people talk about in books like
Napoleon Hill Think and Grow Rich the
secret any of those books where somebody
has a vision of where they want to get
to and they walk that path the reason
that this works for me is that I have my
internal compass lined up so strongly at
what I want that every part of me is
moving in that direction every single
part of me so say that I go out to a
nightclub and I see some guy there who's
got girls all around him looks like you
know he's pimp he's looking cool I'm
seeing that and I'm looking at it and
you know what who knows what the success
is I don't really know but there might
be something about him the way he
carries himself the energy that he has I
look at that and I think I want to be
moving towards that I'm meeting other
people that are good with women and I'm
thinking I want to be moving towards
that and I'm moving towards that always
it's slow doesn't happen overnight very
slow process but the years go by I get
there and you really get there it's like
the coolest thing I could I could
imagine that you could you could have a
vision and you could realize it just to
lining up your internal compass and walk
in the path as it unfolds itself to you
so this is some of the best advice as
well as some of the most frustrating
advice if you want to have success as an
entrepreneur or in your career or
whatever it is wherever you wherever you
see yourself going one of the most
important things that you need to do is
just keep going and that's true advice
but it's also frustrating advice because
you say well I know I need to keep going
but oh I do how do I keep going what are
the steps what's going to get me through
sometimes those steps aren't clear
sometimes experts can't tell you what to
do sometimes you don't know what to do
yourself and sometimes you need to just
get up and do something because I think
a lot of people give up too soon a lot
of people quit the game before they get
their chance a lot of people stop
building momentum before they've had a
chance for that momentum to create an
opportunity for them and sometimes in
chasing your goal it's very specific
right like I want to write a book and I
want to get a major publisher on board
and like everything you're doing is
aligned towards that and sometimes
random opportunity will come and find
you as you're walking along your path
something finds you said I need to go
and do that when I was in university I
had the opportunity to work with my two
founders of the business my first real
company and that wasn't what I thought I
wanted to do and it found me I created
that opportunity for myself and that
exploded my whole world of
entrepreneurship and I had all the signs
up until that point growing up of having
entrepreneurial tendencies and I just
didn't have the awareness that that was
something that I could do until I met
those two people and we had this
successful company and it can be hard to
wake up every day and do something to
further your business to further your
goals to not know what you're gonna do
to not see any momentum to not see any
reaction to not see any growth they're
not seeing any customers not seeing any
likes or shares or comments they're not
getting any tweets they're not getting
any kind of accolades that could suck
but if you really really want this thing
then you have to find a way every single
day to continue down your pie
- keep going to spend 30 to 60 minutes
daily every day minimum at least doing
something to build momentum even if it
feels like what you're doing isn't
working yet keep going
try it again take one more shot find a
different way to stand you only really
start to lose when you stop trying
because if you want to have success you
need to be in the game so stay in the
game stay on the path and eventually if
you stay committed it'll work out just
does so the question today today is I'm
curious what's the hardest part about
staying on the path for you right now
what frustrations are you feeling that's
making you maybe want to leave the path
I'm curious leave in the comments below
I'm gonna join in the discussion I also
want to give a quick shout out to Moe
Mobutu lab Moe thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book your one
word it really really really really
means a lot to me thank you guys for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourselves and
whatever your one word is much love and
I'll see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot events Festa